at this point i think we've all heard
about what's going on with gamestop
stock
the reddit community wall street bets
teamed up to create a short squeeze
which has sent this stock soaring
over the past few trading days this
effort has really blown up
with billionaires like elon musk thomas
palace patia and mark cuban raising
awareness
and even entering the game themselves
but
why are these guys really helping wall
street bets and indirectly promoting
something that is arguably just
[Music]
gambling
before we get started here i wanted to
say congratulations to all you crazy
guys who bought in
and made life-changing amounts of money
on this trade be sure to save
and invest it wisely so that lasts a
long time to come
anyways getting back to the video i
think you guys have all heard dozens of
explanations
as to how short squeezes work so i'll
keep it brief
and use a super simple example i saw on
reddit let's say bananas cost 10 dollars
a piece on the market
and one ape on the market has five
bananas meanwhile
some snakes come along and ask the ape
if they can borrow the bananas for a
week
the ape agrees and gives us five bananas
to the snakes
instead of safely storing the bananas
though the snakes think they can make
some quick money by selling the bananas
on the market for ten dollars apiece
you see the snakes heard some rumors
that the price of bananas is about to go
down to just five dollars a piece
so they figured they can buy the bananas
back for just five dollars a piece
and give it back to ape later on this
way
the snakes can profit a solid 25 dollars
but
unfortunately for the snakes a group of
apes noticed what the snakes were trying
to do
and they decided to get them back the
apes would go out and buy
all the bananas on the market now they
can demand the snakes to pay whatever
price they want
ideally the apes are looking to charge
such a high price that the snakes go
bankrupt trying to buy back the five
benin as they sold
this way the snakes won't be able to
pull a quick one on the other apes any
time
soon but see this entire plan only works
until the apes don't backstab each other
if one of the apes sells their bananas
to snakes for 10
the entire effort is wasted however
if they stay strong together they can
make the snakes regret trying to make
some quick money
in reality the snakes are of course big
banks and the apes are of course a crazy
guys and wall street bets
what's interesting though is that some
pop apes also decide to support the
effort
but why well you see
the papa apes have had their own beef
with the snakes for years for other
reasons
such as market manipulation market
manipulation
is of course unethical and very illegal
but snakes have found several ways to
slither around this
first of all snakes often like to pump
out fake news
this isn't to say that the news itself
is fake but
they painted in a misleading way for
example
take tesla's recent run-up before the s
p 500 inclusion
during the run-up the street post an
article titled tesla trading at 650
gets a 90 price target from jp morgan
they could have titled the article tesla
gets a price upgrade from jp morgan
as their previous price target was only
but they didn't do that and that's not
just to get clicks on their page
rather the market makers or the snakes
want people holding tesla stock to sell
so that they themselves can buy the
stock for cheaper
investors who have been in the game for
a while are easily able to see past
this manipulation and they won't sell
their stock no matter what
however as tesla was getting added into
the s p 500
many brand new investors were getting
into the stock and
they weren't so aware of these games
they also weren't aware that jp morgan's
previous price target
was only 80 as a result many of them
sold when they heard that the biggest
bank in the world
thought tesla was worth ninety dollars a
share consequently
tesla stock tumbled from 660 to 570
in a matter of hours but the next day
tesla didn't continue to go down towards
90 a share like jp morgan predicted
instead it quickly bounced back into the
600s
i'm sure that seasoned investors buying
the dip accelerated this rebound
but i have a feeling that jp morgan was
buying a dip
as well after all they just happened to
own 4.7
billion dollars worth of a stock they
think it's about to crash 85 percent
as you can see drumming up fear to buy
for cheaper prices
is extremely common amongst big banks
and hedge funds
this same principle works the other way
too whenever a big player wants to exit
a position for whatever reason
they'll drum up excitement in the market
take apple's recent quarterly earnings
report for instance
apple had a blowout quarter destroying
expectations with the monster
100 billion quarter the media has
likewise been hyping up these earnings
for weeks
and all the articles that came out
afterwards were also
very positive but for some random reason
throughout the actual day of earnings
apple stock would dump from 145
to 137 dollars now that might not sound
like a lot
but for a company as large as apple
that's a massive move
that drop is equivalent to apple's
market cap dropping 130
billion dollars anyways as you can see
creating artificial excitement and fear
through the media is one of the primary
ways
big money manipulates the market another
popular manipulation method that hedge
funds often turn to
is bear or bull rating hedge funds
and the big banks have a lot of money
and with that comes a lot of influence
as a result whenever they're looking to
add on to or take away from their
position
they bull or bear raid the market a bear
raid is when someone dumps their shares
onto the market
in order to create short-term fear hedge
funds usually utilize this method when
they want to add on to their position
for instance let's say a hedge fund has
10 billion worth of amazon
stock they want to add another 10
billion onto their portfolio
but they don't want to pay market price
for these shares
so what they might do is sell 1 billion
worth of amazon stock
in one go this will of course cost the
stock price
to trend downwards stock traders will
often pick up on this
and will exit their position while they
still have profits on the table
which will add to the sell-off as this
downward movement starts to gain
traction
we'll see people stop losses getting
triggered adding on even more selling
pressure
before you know it the stock will be
down two or three percent
which is again massive numbers for a
company as large as amazon
and this is when the hedge fund will go
ahead and add the 10 billion dollar
stake
onto their position conversely if
they're looking to get out of amazon
they'll do the exact opposite they would
go ahead and
buy one billion dollars worth of amazon
stock which will create momentum upwards
and allow them to scale out of their
position
if they don't want to actually invest
money into the stock or liquidate their
current position
they might use yet another strategy
which is spoofing
the stock market is quite tricky to
understand especially for beginners
so what many beginners do is copy what
big players do
by using software that tracks big
movements big players
are well aware of this and use spoofing
to take advantage of these beginners
if hedge funds don't want a specific
stock to fall below a certain level
what they might do is place a market
order for millions of dollars at the
desired price
for instance if microsoft stock is at
and a hedge fund is interested in
keeping the stock up of 200
they might place a 10 million buy order
at 200
abnormal buy and sell order tracking
software will quickly pick up on this
massive order
and tell retail investors that some
whale is trying to buy microsoft if it
drops to 200
considering that many beginner investors
mindlessly follow such orders
many of them will end up putting in
orders for 200
however once the stock reaches around
201 dollars
the hedge fund will cancel their 200
order thus the retail investors will end
up being the ones buying in at 200
and paying the fall for the hedge fund
anyways
hedge funds market makers and big banks
have dozens of similar strategies
that they employ on a daily basis to
move the market in their favor
as a result beginner retail investors
end up losing billions
upon billions of dollars collectively
every single year
which this makes pocket as easy profit
considering that tesla is one of the
most manipulated stocks on the market
elon musk has obviously not been a very
big fan of these snakes for quite some
time
so when gamestop started to run up
causing the shorts to lose billions of
dollars
he was quick to raise awareness using
his twitter account tweeting gamestonk
and linking the wall street bets
community on reddit
what made this even more appealing for
him was that many of the shorts that
were losing money on gamestop
were the same people who were previously
shorting tesla like melvin capital
and citron in 2018 tesla was the most
shortest stock
in the world and as tesla was struggling
to ramp up model 3 production
these shorts were continuously running
bad articles about tesla
suggesting that tesla was going to zero
evidently
elon musk didn't hesitate when he had
the opportunity to get back at these
shorts
big time meanwhile chalmette has been
watching many retail investors getting
crushed by
big banks for decades thus he too took
this opportunity to hurt the shorters
on the morning of january 26th he would
throw a little over one hundred thousand
dollars at gamestop call options
he would receive a lot of criticism for
encouraging team gamblers
and essentially running a pump and dumb
scheme but really
at the end of the day neither of these
are the goals of any of these
billionaires
i'm sure that all of them are truly
happy to see the little guys winning
unlike the media but their primary goal
is much bigger than just making you guys
money their main goal is to put some of
the businesses that have been screwing
over retail investors for years
out of business and when everything is
said and done
this may very well be what transpires
what do you guys think about this
mission
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys enjoy seeing big money
finally getting a bit of karma
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you